so the senate failed to procure enough
votes to convict former president trump
of the charge of incitement to
insurrection
and thus in a way the senate has
acquitted president trump of his
record-second impeachment for many this
was a faticon plea that there was simply
no way it was possible for
the democrats or anyone else to convince
enough republicans to
form the necessary two-thirds majority
in order to convict on impeachment but
even still this was a marked difference
from the first impeachment trial and a
record number of
members of the same party as the former
president
voted to convict let's take a look at
the five days that comprise the
impeachment trial
examine the legal arguments and see if
this was indeed inevitable and whether
the arguments on the prosecution side
and the defense side
held any water
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
an impeachment lawyer because former
president trump was able to escape
conviction on impeachment
for a record second time but this time
only narrowly
now as we've talked about many times on
this channel an impeachment trial
is not a criminal trial you know this
you know that it is a political trial or
more specifically it is a trial by
parliament and lawyers like myself like
to make analogies to the criminal
justice system but these analogies are
always imperfect and this moves in
several different directions so we're
going to be talking about things like
due process
and the hearsay rule but often these
things are
completely incoherent in an impeachment
setting because the senate
makes its own rules it can adopt the
federal rules of evidence but it doesn't
have to
and due process considerations that
exist for private citizens
in the criminal justice system simply do
not exist
in an impeachment setting but that
doesn't necessarily mean that we need to
throw any of that out it just
means that it might not necessarily
carry the day and we saw this throughout
the impeachment trial with lawyers
making contradictory arguments
uh with senators justifying their
reasons for voting or not voting for
conviction of impeachment in ways that
absolutely do not jive with the criminal
justice system
and we also saw it in things like a
group of senators meeting with the
defense lawyers we saw senators cruz
graham
and lee actually meet with president
trump's surrogates to discuss the
defense of the president and people were
absolutely right to point out that
in a criminal justice setting members of
the jury meeting
and strategizing with attorneys for
either side would be completely improper
this is not a criminal justice sitting
literally the impeachment clause of the
constitution does not allow for criminal
penalties it's
on the narrow issue of preventing
someone from holding
office again so look politicians are
going to be politicians
but that being said let's dive into the
legal arguments that were made
so let's start with the very first
foundational jurisdictional question of
whether the senate can even hold an
impeachment hearing
related to an official who is no longer
in that position the first day of the
impeachment trial was devoted to this
very question because
generally you have to determine issues
of law before you can get to the issues
of fact
some argue that the constitution doesn't
answer this question directly
so let's start with the historical
context that the framers were dealing
with because as hamilton wrote
england provided the model from which
the idea of this institution has been
borrowed
in fact every impeachment that occurred
during the framers lifetime actually
concerned a
former official and the consensus of the
first states to draft their own
constitutions was that impeachment of
former officials was not banned
every single state constitution in the
1780s either
specifically said that former officials
could be impeached
or were entirely consistent with the
idea
in contrast not a single state
constitution
prohibited trials of former officials
and virginia delaware vermont and
pennsylvania explicitly permitted late
impeachment in their state constitutions
which were written before the us
constitution and generally speaking in
the pre-constitutional era
officers were impeached after they left
office in vermont for example state
representative jonathan fassett was
impeached after he joined an angry mob
that wanted to stop a county court from
convening huh
i wonder if that sounds familiar he was
impeached and later convicted after he
left office
and the constitution was being hashed
out during the same month that british
governor general of india william
hastings was being impeached for
corruption
hastings was already out of office at
the time the people who drafted the
constitution repeatedly referred to the
hastings impeachment in an offhand
manner
the same way that people in our era may
refer to the clinton impeachment without
getting into the gritty details
and apparently the founders did not
object to the lateness of this
impeachment instead
they used it to show why impeachment was
important george mason noted that
hastings committed a slew of crimes but
none of them fit the definition of
treason mason warned that the definition
of treason in the us constitution
would not include attempts to quote
subvert the constitution therefore
impeachment should include high crimes
and misdemeanors and george mason
certainly imagines someone like donald
trump in other words mason thought that
making a character judgment
was an important part of the scheme of
checks and balances between the branches
of government
so lin-manuel where is george mason's
musical so not surprisingly almost the
entire first day of the impeachment
trial was devoted to this legal question
can the senate hold the impeachment
trial related to
an official who is either resigned or
whose term has expired
and generally that's a good idea because
if this was a criminal trial
you would almost always dispose of all
the legal questions before getting to
the issues of fact
and that's especially important here
because this is a political question
where the supreme court
would never touch it with a 10-foot pole
in other words
even if former president trump was
convicted there's no way that he could
try to appeal this to the federal courts
and say that
this was improper or unconstitutional
the supreme court would 100 percent
never answer it because this is a
political question that is left up to
the judicial branch
and so given that on the first day the
senate held a vote
and held that by a majority that the
senate believed it had jurisdiction to
hold this
impeachment trial one would think that
this legal question was settled but of
course
this is partially a political question
and thus the senators can do
whatever they want for basically
whatever reasons they want but there is
i think
one important analogy to the criminal
justice system that applies in a
situation like this
because the way that a criminal trial
would work is that the lawyers and the
judge would hash out all of the legal
issues
and eventually once those things are
hashed out the judge will give the jury
instructions to the jury that
gives them all of the law that they need
to understand the decision that they're
going to make
and there's a phrase that we use to
describe what happens when a jury
disregards those kind of instructions
and
makes a decision based on whatever
rationale they want and that phrase
is jury nullification and it's
completely reasonable to say that
several members of the senate
engaged in jury nullification to find
former president trump
not guilty and then there's also the
doctrine of unclean hands because
it's not like the date of this trial was
set in stone
from on high let's not forget that
former senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell was in control of the senate's
schedule
and prevented the senate from holding a
trial on
former president trump while he was
still in office
and that's particularly galling when
mitch mcconnell used that timing as the
reason that he
didn't vote to convict saying that
impeachment is primarily a tool for
removal though
he leaves open the the argument that
impeachment can be used outside
of that context which the majority of
legal scholars believe
as well and some have argued again
analogizing to the criminal justice
system that
if you in fact believe that the senate
doesn't have jurisdiction
then you can't participate in that vote
but there is one senator who i think
threaded this needle and actually came
to a principled stance
while fundamentally disagreeing with
some of these jurisdictional questions
and that's
senator richard burr from north carolina
who recognized that he couldn't hide
behind the unconstitutionality argument
and voted to convict he stated quote
when this process started i believe that
it was unconstitutional to impeach a
president who was no longer in office
i still believe that to be the case
however the senate is an institution
based on precedent and given that the
majority of the senate voted to proceed
with this trial the question of
constitutionality is now established
precedent
as an impartial juror my role is now to
determine whether house managers have
sufficiently made the case for the
article of impeachment
against president trump i've listened to
the arguments presented by both sides
and considered the facts
the facts are clear and then voted for
conviction those are the words of
someone who had
a reasonable argument related to the
process of the impeachment trial
but then did his duty based on his
position as the impeachment went forward
so with that historical context let's
look at the actual text of the
constitution
article 2 section 4 says quote the
president vice president and all civil
officers of the united states
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction of
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors
trump argues that the plain meaning of
the word officer means a person who
currently holds office not an ex-officer
the phrase removed from office in this
context would mean that once a person
was already gone
he or she cannot be removed and trump
lawyer david schoen
addressed his argument in his trial
brief but didn't discuss it in
any detail during his opening statement
the democrats argue that the question of
whether a former official can be tried
as part of the impeachment process
depends not just on the language of
article 2 section 4 but also depends on
other sections of the constitution that
deal with
impeachment they begin with a question
how does the constitution describe the
accused in an impeachment trial
we already know that article 2 section 4
simply says the president vice president
and all civil officers can be removed
trump's lawyers rely exclusively on this
provision to make their argument that
only current officers can be impeached
and the house managers rely on chuck
cooper a staunchly conservative lawyer
who has represented republicans
including minority leader mark meadows
as cooper says
article 2 section 4 means just what it
says in the first half
describes what an official must do to be
impeached namely commit high crimes and
misdemeanors
and the second half describes what
happens when civil officers
of the united states including the
sitting president are convicted
removal from office that's it in
cooper's words that establishes what is
known in the criminal law as a mandatory
minimum punishment
and then we move on to the next section
to define the identity of the accused
and impeachment trial
the house managers also rely on article
1 section 3 clause 6 and 7
which refer to a person and a party
rather than a president vice president
or civil officer
clause 6 quote the senate shall have the
sole power to try all impeachments when
sitting for that purpose they shall be
on oath or affirmation when the
president of the united states is tried
the chief justice
shall preside and no person shall be
convicted without the concurrence of
two-thirds of the members present
then we move on to clause number seven
quote judgment in cases of impeachment
shall not extend further than removal
from office and
disqualification to hold enjoyment of
any office of honor trust or profit on
the united states
but the party convicted shall
nevertheless be liable and subject to
indictment trial
and punishment according to law so here
we have the words person and party
rather than a civil officer in
describing the accused
arguably this word choice includes
former officials who could be on tr
put on trial rather for impeachment
other than civil officers who else could
a person or a party be well really
there's
only one possible answer former officers
and then circling back to some prior
language that we read the house managers
also direct our attention back to the
language of article 1 section 3
which states judgment in cases of
impeachment shall not extend further
than to removal from office and
disqualification
representative joe negus gave a master
class in the construction of these words
the constitution does not say
removal from office and then
disqualification
it doesn't say removal from office
followed by disqualification
now on the other hand the trump argument
is that the and binds both the removal
and disqualification together and thus
you can't have a removal of someone
who's already been removed from office
meaning that
therefore you can't have the
disqualification against someone who's
already been removed from office
the vast majority of legal scholars do
not adhere to this particular
interpretation and are following what
representative
nagus was already arguing but then we go
back to article 1 section 3 which states
that the senate shall have the sole
power to try all
impeachments the house managers argue
that all means all it doesn't say the
senate has the power to try impeachments
against sitting officers
what we're left with is an impeachment
mechanism that includes four possible
punishments impeachment by the house
removal from office by the senate
disqualification from holding office
again
and a criminal prosecution in a court of
law and of course many have argued the
policy argument that if disqualification
was subject to a time limit
that creates a dangerous loophole a
potential january exception
officials could commit the most
extraordinary destructive offenses
against the american people high crimes
and misdemeanors they'd have
total control over whether they can ever
be impeached and if they are
whether the senate can try the case if
they want to escape any public inquiry
into
their misconduct or the risk of
disqualification from future office and
it's pretty simple they just could just
resign
one minute before the house impeaches or
even one minute before the senate trial
or
they could resign during the senate
trial if it's not looking so well
that would effectively erase
disqualification from the constitution
so assuming that this impeachment trial
is legitimate which the overwhelming
weight of legal authority seems to
suggest
that takes us to the arguments for the
conviction
on impeachment and the arguments against
on days two
and three of the impeachment trial house
managers made their case arguing for
conviction
house managers spent most of day two
presenting new footage of the riots
themselves and honestly it's
shocking and let's take a moment to
recognize a true american hero eugene
goodman
who appears to have single-handedly
saved the life of mitt romney and
countless other representatives and
senators
a man whose quick thinking saved lives
and whose decision not to use his gun
also spared the lives of countless
rioters and we forget that this
easily could have been a massacre in two
different directions not only the
politicians
but also the rioters and protesters
themselves and while
many would have cheered that on that too
would have been an american tragedy
and it's only through the quick thinking
of people like eugene goodman
that that tragedy was averted so let's
start with the arguments of the house
managers in their trial brief they argue
that this trial rises from president
donald j
trump's incitement of insurrection
against the republic he swore to protect
the house impeachment managers walked
through the lead-up to january 6
discussing how the trump campaign
refused to concede
that trump lost the election even after
trump lost over 60 legal cases related
to the election he refused to
accept the loss and instead saying he
won in a landslide and
the vote was stolen from him former
president trump also pressured state
election officials state representatives
governors and u.s attorneys to overturn
the will of the people
in their states after the electoral
college voted to certify
president biden's win former president
trump asked his supporters to come to
washington on january 6 to quote stop
the steal
january 6 was the day that congress
would meet to certify the election and
trump told his supporters that the
results could be changed on
that day trump spent approximately 50
million dollars on a campaign to
stop the steal these ads were designed
to run
all the way up to january 5.
and then they stopped leading many to
suspect that
the trump campaign didn't actually think
that there was any value
in art making the arguments after the
sixth and putting everything into that
date
the trump campaign helped plan the event
on january 6.
trump selected the date because this was
the day that biden's win would be
finalized
the constitution says you have to
protect our country and you have to
protect our constitution
and you can't vote on fraud and fraud
breaks up everything doesn't it
when you catch somebody in a fraud
you're allowed to go by
very different rules so i hope
mike has the courage to do what he has
to do
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
trump told them that mike pence could
overturn the election results
right after trump was informed that vice
president pence had been evacuated due
to
all of the supporters invading the
capital minutes later he tweeted
to the mob that pence was a coward mike
pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
usa demands the truth the mob yelled
trump's tweet into a bullhorn while they
went into the capitol building the mob
searched for pence the mob searched for
the votes and the mob searched for
other elected representatives who were
going through with the
election certification and as
demonstrated by his calls to senators
tuberville and lee trump was willing to
use the violence
to his effective advantage as leverage
to try and get them to do something to
stop the certification
so this is the factual basis for the
article's impeachment from the house now
let's talk about the legal basis
the house argues that these actions were
high crimes and misdemeanors i've done
many other videos on the meaning of high
crimes and misdemeanors but suffice to
say almost all legal scholars agree that
the term was meant to include
transgressions that were not necessarily
actual crimes prohibited by federal law
since there wasn't
very much federal law at the time and
that it was
a catch-all for things that are a
violation of public trust
certainly actual crimes could be high
crimes and misdemeanors as well but it's
not
necessary that a president be removed
because of an actual statutory crime
and as we've discussed the founders
believe that the actions against the
state which subvert the government were
impeachable
as alexander hamilton described them as
actions which are quote political as
they relate chiefly to injuries done
immediately to society itself
historically politicians have taken the
position that these offenses could be
even
moral such as having an affair and then
lying under oath to cover it up
the house democrats write that quote if
provoking an insurrection riot against a
joint session of congress after losing
an election
is not an impeachable offense it's hard
to imagine what would be
the house argues that trump attacked the
foundations of the democratic process
itself quote
under absolutely no circumstance may a
candidate for any position
at any level of government respond to
electoral defeat by provoking
armed violence and the house managers
anticipating the arguments of trump's
defense that he had
a first amendment right to say whatever
he wanted whenever he wanted
the house managers have two counter
arguments that the first amendment is
not a defense to
the actions and statements that were
made on january 6
and the lead up to january 6. first they
say that president trump should be held
to a higher standard of conduct than a
private citizen quote
no one would seriously suggest that a
president should be immunized from
impeachment
if he publicly championed the adoption
of a totalitarian government swore an
oath of eternal loyalty to a foreign
power
or advocated that states secede from and
overthrow the union
even though private citizens could be
protected by the first amendment for
such speech
the house impeachment managers argued
that interfering with the peaceful
transfer power
with violence is an assault on core
first amendment principles
and the house's second argument is that
there's already quite a bit of first
amendment jurisprudence on the limits of
some speech that speech is not protected
where it is quote directed to inciting
or producing imminent lawless action
and is likely to incite or produce such
action i've already covered whether
former president trump's speech incited
the riot in another video from a
criminal law perspective and there are
certainly
arguments on either side but the
impeachment is not about whether
former president trump violated a
criminal statute and is going to jail
the impeachment trial literally cannot
result in a
jail conviction it says specifically in
the constitution that
that is not allowed it's about whether
his conduct as a whole was so serious
that america should send a message to
future presidents and to
insurrectionists and whether it should
punish the speech that was actually made
by preventing such a transgressor from
being able to hold
office again and that takes us to the
third argument of the democratic house
managers which is again anticipating
arguments from the trump camp they argue
that late impeachments are
absolutely constitutional the house
cites the same authorities that we
talked about earlier in this video
talking about how late impeachments are
both constitutional and have a fairly
long history
and they also rely on old writings of
professor jonathan turley one of trump's
chief defenders
turley wrote several journal articles
that impeaching ex-presidents is
constitutional professor turley argued
that the house could have impeached and
the senate
could have tried richard nixon after he
resigned quote
future presidents could not assume that
mere resignation would avoid a trial of
their conduct
in the united states senate no man in no
circumstance can escape the account
which he owes to the laws of his country
of course it's also important to point
out that president trump was not
impeached after he left office he was
impeached
when he was in office and now it's up to
the senate to try it and
in fact as many have pointed out mitch
mcconnell could have allowed the senate
to conduct the trial
before former president trump left
office but
this is not a case of the impeachment
happening after the resignation or after
the official has left
office the impeachment the indictment
phase already happened
while trump was president of course
turley has been featured heavily on fox
news arguing the exact opposite of his
earlier views
without saying why and how his hundreds
of pages of arguments
are now false but jonathan turley is
going to jonathan turley
uh what they're citing is an article
from 21 years ago
and the house manager's arguments also
sound in classic penological theory one
point arguing it's making sure
that no future official no future
president
does the same exact thing president
trump does
what they're arguing is in fact
deterrence both individual in general
they want to make sure that
former president trump himself never has
an opportunity to do the things that he
did
as well as making sure that no one like
former president trump does it in the
future as well
as well as the common justification of
punitive measures
punishing former president trump for the
actions that he did undertake those are
the classic reasons as to why you would
incarcerate someone
in jail in the first place so that takes
us to
former president trump's arguments the
house impeachment managers cite trump's
actions and words and conduct from
before during and after the riot
trump on the other hand has chosen to
focus on narrow issues of whether his
january 6 speech
would have made him liable for the
actual crime of incitement
of imminent lawless action trump camp
argues that
president trump did not commit the crime
of incitement and focus
on the text of the january 6 speech
trump argued in his brief quote words do
matter in the words of president trump's
january 6 speech
speak for themselves of the over 10 000
words spoken mr trump used the word
fight a little more than a handful of
times and each time in the figurative
sense
that has long been accepted in public
discourse when urging people to stand
and use their voices
to be heard on matters important as the
trump camp points out
the former president spoke for about an
hour but never advocated for violence or
told anyone to get their weapons
although he told them to head over to
the capitol he did not go with them nor
did he tell them to storm the building
and the trump camp is focused on
language that doesn't fit the house
manager's narrative
focusing on statements like quote i know
that everyone here will soon be marching
over to the capitol building to
peacefully and patriotically
make your voices heard and the next big
argument that the trump camp makes is
that the senate simply doesn't have
jurisdiction
over a former public official citing the
constitutional text we referred to
earlier former president trump's lawyer
spent most of day four laying out their
defense as it was and by the way i'm not
particularly impressed by
trump's legal defense team here with
respect to bruce castor
he legitimately seemed to be confused at
many different times it seems like he
winged
everything and often when it was clear
he was not talking from his notes he
would go back to his notes and sometimes
the things that he
had written out ahead of time were worse
than the things he was just talking
about
off the cuff you know it's interesting
because i don't want to steal the
thunder from
the other lawyers but nebraska you're
going to hear
is quite a judicial
thinking place with respect to david
showing he seemed to think that the
louder he yelled the more persuasive he
was
and he was very wrong about that and
then there's michael van der veen who is
a personal injury lawyer who absolutely
looked and sounded like a personal
injury lawyer who
had absolutely no understanding of the
grand stage that he was on
these depositions should be done in
person in my office
in philadelphia this was a b team of
lawyers filling in for former president
trump after his first
legal team quit on mass and it
absolutely showed at many times the
trump team
argued that former president trump was
not afforded due process
and therefore the whole thing should
just be thrown out
this argument i find particularly
galling because on the one hand they're
saying that
investigations should be done
depositions should be taken in
the exact same time they're also arguing
that the whole thing should be thrown
out because too much time was taken too
much time has passed and now
trump is no longer in office and thus
there's no jurisdiction for this
impeachment at all
and yes lawyers argue in the alternative
all the time but that doesn't mean that
that's a persuasive
tactic to take and here as we've talked
about many times
the requirements for a criminal
conviction simply don't apply here the
beyond a reasonable doubt standard does
not apply in impeachments and there's a
lot of confusion
about the term incitement itself
incitement means a lot of different
things it is number one a
crime under most jurisdictions it's also
an exception to the first amendment
in terms of speech that is not protected
by the first amendment
it is a political offense as to
something that the senate might feel is
unbecoming of the president himself
and thus warrants removal or being
barred from public office
and it's also being used as just a
shorthand for everything that happened
and because you have these different
definitions going across purposes
a lot of the different arguments are
like ships passing in the night and it's
all bound up in this question of whether
the president should be held to a higher
standard than your average citizen or
a lower one and remember the vast
majority of legal weight says that the
president doesn't have to be guilty of
an actual crime
to be impeached removed and barred from
office
and playing off of that confusion the
trump lawyers
created a video montage of democrats
using the
term fight in contexts that don't rise
to the level of incitement
of course many people argued the counter
that of course
it depends on the context that it also
depends on the intent none of these
democratic members of congress ever had
the intention to
actually incite violence that the
violence was not incited no riot ever
came about of these words and that the
context was incredibly different but the
point is valid that different words can
mean different things
in different contexts but it really
feels like these arguments were a false
equivalence and a lot of what aboutism
and apart from the due process arguments
the trump lawyers
argued extensively about hearsay and
this
makes me want to pull out my own hair
for several different reasons first of
all as we've talked about many different
times the senate can use whatever
standard it wants and generally it has
almost always allowed hearsay as
evidence in
impeachment trials but more to the point
almost all the hearsay statements
at issue here would be admissible in
trial because
they weren't being used for the truth of
the matter asserted which is necessary
for
hearsay but rather they were being used
for the
state of mind of former president trump
and his intent
which is a non-hearsay purpose to the
statements themselves so yes
they were out of court statements but
not all out-of-court statements
are inadmissible and the vast majority
of the things being discussed here would
probably have been admissible
and putting apart the fact that almost
all of the senators who are
participating
in this particular trial were first-hand
witnesses
and the hearsay wasn't really necessary
for them to make their decisions because
they were
a part and parcel to witnessing all of
this stuff but perhaps the biggest irony
is that the defense
extensively used hearsay themselves the
entire defense case
because president trump wasn't willing
to testify himself
relied on out-of-court statements so if
you're going to exclude a whole bunch of
the prosecution's case
on the basis they're out of court
statements then you have to disregard
the entire defense case
now there was big news after the fourth
day of the impeachment trial when
representative herrera butler a
republican came forward and relayed
part of the conversation that she had
with representative kevin mccarthy of
california this conversation
seemed to dispute basically everything
the defense had said about
former president trump's knowledge about
what was going on at the time
in the middle of the insurrection when
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
called the president to beg for help
president trump responded and i quote
well kevin i guess these people are more
upset about the election
than you are now if this were a court
case it is possible to get double
hearsay
or hearsay within hearsay to be
admissible you just need an exception
for both layers of the hearsay and
arguably that's met because
between trump and mccarthy that would go
to president trump's state of mind and
as between mccarthy and herrera butler
that could be a present sense impression
or excited utterance
based on the circumstances that there
would be an exception to the hearsay
rule and
arguably that statement would be
admissible in court and that takes us to
the third argument that the trump
lawyers make which is that
an impeachment of a private citizen is
really a bill of attender now this is an
argument that probably made a lot of
first-year law students extremely happy
because
bills of attainder don't come up that
often but trump argues that the
impeachment trial by the senate of a
private citizen
violates article 1 section 9 of the us
constitution which states that no bill
of attainder
shall be passed what is a bill of
attainer well that is basically a
prohibition on congress from enacting
any law that
legislatively determines guilt and
inflicts punishment upon an
identifiable individual without
provisions of the protections of a
judicial trial
now according to trump this impeachment
in every impeachment is a bill of
detainer because it allows the
legislature to
make a finding of guilt a bill of
detainers the kind of legislative
act that only has effect when it's
adopted by both houses of congress and
signed into law by the president
impeachment and removal by contrast
though can be accomplished by
congress alone and most importantly it's
written
into the text of the constitution so if
a bill of attainder were to nullify the
impeachment clause
that would be a big problem and uh
there's no interpretation of the
constitution where that can possibly
be uh correct and this means that trump
is legally incorrect in saying that a
conviction
of the senate counts as a bill of
attender the senate isn't voting on any
such bill it's
putting former president trump on trial
for
impeachment which is part of the
constitution itself
the president joe biden doesn't have a
role in impeachment and there have been
all kinds of bad faith arguments about
saying that you can't deprive someone
of life liberty or property without due
process but
the due process is the impeachment trial
itself and on top of that
this is not a deprivation of the normal
fourth amendment rights
it's written into the constitution that
you can
have an impeachment that has the
punishment of preventing someone from
being able to hold office again it's
written into the constitution itself
but this distinction between a bill of
attender and impeachment goes back
far into english common law under the
law english monarchs would have to sign
off on any bills of a tander and
impeachment was added as a tool
precisely because it did not need
royal consent it gave parliament the
ability to constrain the executive power
and the american founders were not fond
of bills of attainder because they
effectively allowed the government to
make
a post-hoc decision about punishing
someone criminally
as an individual private citizen but
they really liked impeachment because
they feared a monarch coming to the
american executive this was
the whole reason for the revolution to
begin with that they wanted to cast
aside the monarchy so this takes us to
one of the main thrusts of the trump
lawyers which is that the first
amendment
prohibits impeachment for words trump
argues that the impeachment invites
senators to violate the first amendment
principle of freedom of speech
and trump says that impeachment itself
is always constrained by free speech
quote
the constitution must at a minimum serve
as a limitation on the ability of
congress to impeach for high crimes and
misdemeanors
here trump is essentially saying that
the government i.e the house of
representatives is trampling on his free
speech rights
by impeaching him for things that he
said and did and the crux of this
argument is that congress cannot impeach
a person for
constitutional conduct and if we tried
to apply this principle consistently
then other articles of impeachment
against other presidents would also have
to be rejected
bill clinton arguably had a 4th and 14th
amendment privacy right to consensual
sexual conduct with another adult
and a first amendment right to lie about
it but the problem is there's all kinds
of
legally and morally impermissible acts
that are based
solely in speech defamation is a solely
speech-based act for the most part
bribery tends to be a speech-based act
when you're
making a bargain with an elected
official for their own pecuniary
interest
that's a based in speech and there's
basically no argument that some of these
things
wouldn't give rise to impeachment and
the trump lawyers tried to blend
legal and political arguments together
the trump lawyers accuse the house
managers of creating an impeachment
process that yields to the
unbridled whims of house managers but a
bipartisan group of legislators in the
house believe that trump's conduct and
words were impeachable
trump argues that they were all
motivated by trump derangement syndrome
but this is really a legal argument it's
a political one and it's one that
of course he's free to make but it
doesn't seem to hold water on
a legal basis the house of course argues
that it didn't impeach president trump
because he expressed an unpopular
political opinion but rather it
impeached him because he was willfully
inciting a violent insurrection against
the government
they argued quote we live in a nation
governed by the rule of law not mob
violence incited by presidents who
cannot accept
their own electoral defeat and of course
president trump argues that he did not
commit a violation of law trump argues
the
same position in this impeachment that
he did the first time around that the
president can only be impeached if he
violates a criminal statute the trump
lawyers argue that the only relevant
inquiry is whether trump's january 6
speech incited people to imminent
lawless action and
to determine whether it did we should
not consider the broader environment in
which the speech was actually made we
should
only look narrowly at the actual text
itself
and on the fifth day of the impeachment
trial the big drama came as a result of
the democrats winning a vote to be able
to call
witnesses at the trial but then backing
down accepting a stipulation of the
herrera butler statement and then moving
forward with closing arguments now
personally i would have liked to have
seen witnesses i think that it would
have been good for historical reasons to
lay
even more of a factual foundation for
everything that went on
and to be able to force some of the
testimony related to
things that former president trump may
or may not have been thinking
and when he was thinking them but at the
same time it's probably not the case
that witnesses would have actually
changed the results of this impeachment
trial
and at the end of the day 57 senators
voted to convict former president trump
which was not enough for the two-thirds
majority
needed for conviction and the number is
a record there were seven republican
senators who voted to convict trump
and that is seven times greater than the
previous number of senators who voted to
convict a president of their own party
which that number was set by senator
mitt romney just a year ago in president
trump's first impeachment trial
so the question is what happens next
i suspect that there will probably be
commissions subpoenas
investigations and criminal prosecutions
remember
the impeachment punishment is extremely
narrow it's simply removal from office
and being barred from running again
theoretically impeachment itself
is dead if under these circumstances the
president
cannot be impeached then doesn't seem
like there is any realistic scenario
where any president will ever be
impeached which
in itself is i think a worrying trend
and even though mitch mcconnell voted to
acquit
president trump he still recognizes that
trump is liable for everything that he
did in office and
seems to be almost asking prosecutors to
criminally prosecute former president
trump
they did this because they'd been fed
wild falsehoods
by the most powerful man on earth and
bad news for those that want to invoke
the 14th amendment to bar people who
have
participated in sedition against the
united states from holding office
the 57 senate votes that were
secured to convict president trump on
impeachment are not enough votes for
cloture so
given that the filibuster still exists
there's not going to be enough votes to
actually bar him under the 14th
amendment assuming that the votes stay
the same
but there is some good news given that
this was truly a bipartisan effort with
both members of the house and seven
republican senators who voted for
conviction
this is probably a green light for
criminal prosecutions normally you would
assume that
state district attorneys or the u.s
attorney general would be extremely
reluctant
to engage in a criminal investigation of
a former president
but given the overwhelming bipartisan
support it sort of signals to those law
enforcement officers that
you can proceed if there is indeed a
true criminal violation by former
president trump
and there's also more good news isn't
that the threat of impeachment probably
restrained former president trump in the
last days of his presidency
so generally i'm feeling pretty good
about this whole affair yes
i wish they had called witnesses and
made the record even more clear and
frankly
rubbed the noses of the republicans in
their own filth for a little bit longer
but the record was already one thousand
percent clear this was not a failing by
the house managers to make a case
the outcome was already a feta complete
mitch mcconnell wouldn't allow trial
while trump was still in office and then
hid behind his own political maneuvering
as a reason for why he couldn't vote for
conviction
and let's face it sometimes even futile
gestures are worth doing
because it's the right thing to do seven
republicans voted for conviction and
that's
absolutely no small feat in this
hyper-partisan world
this is not a win for the trump camp
they should not be
high-fiving thinking that they did a
good job here and i think history will
be absolutely clear on this point it
will show that the acquittal
was a miscarriage of justice just like
the acquittal of andrew johnson
and the acquittal of donald trump the
first time around
but let me know if you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here where i talk about all of the
legal issues that happened in the trump
administration that
led up to the impeachment so click on
this playlist or i'll see you
in court